meu nome do devedor eu sou o professor
daqui do werneck e antes de mais nada
gostaria de pedir para vocês o seguinte
se eu fizer alguma piada que dêem risada
favor da gente porque é meio difícil
takita
hoje vou falar sobre a vida e como é uma
grande sala de aula e pra isso eu trouxe
a caixa ela representa na minha vida eu
gostaria de perguntar pra vocês o
seguinte
quantos de vocês são professores levanta
a mão
já agora quantos de vocês já aprenderam
algo com a vida
levanta a mão pois é na primeira
pergunta algum só levantar a mão na
segunda praticamente todo mundo levantou
a mão pra vocês que todos vocês são
professores porque o ensino ele está em
todo lugar e ele aja a vida ágio de uma
forma que usam de vocês pra ensinar uns
aos outros porque se todo mundo já
aprendeu algo com a vida aprendemos com
quem como ela está em todo lugar
o ensino ele não é só conteúdo o ensino
também é o processo ou seja é a forma
como aquele conteúdo está sendo aplicado
é a forma como nós aprendemos a gente
fosse fazer uma analogia o ensino seria
um copo com água em que o copo é o
processo e água o conteúdo se não tiver
um copo a água não tem não tem como ter
forma eu gostaria de mostrar isso eu
gostaria de mostrar pra vocês três fases
da minha vida conta três histórias um em
cada fase da minha vida
na primeira fase criança eu tinha oito
anos
essa é uma foto de quando era criança
vamos analisar essa foto tá é existe uma
metalinguagem alina que existe uma foto
da foto
eu não sei qual foi a minha mãe não sei
qual foi
eu acho que eles quiseram fazer isso
mesmo existe um ninja vermelho do meu
lado
gravem bem já vermelho e ainda bem que
vencemos né
é talvez a isso ea minha esposa fala
ainda bem que venceu porque essa criança
aí né
graças a deus ela envelheceu e o que tem
de importante nessa foto
duas coisas o fato de oito anos eo ninja
mesmo guarda chuva vermelho quando tinha
oito anos eu descobrir os meus dois
primeiros professores da vida dos meus
pais
nós éramos muito pobres assim a gente
vivia numa casa de 40 metros quadrados
em maria da graça para a sala e tal
meus pais trabalhavam muito muito muito
muito os dois trabalhavam muito pra
gente ter o que comer e acontece uma
coisa que né
a minha mãe ela foi demitida e semanas
depois a nossa casa foi assaltada
levaram tudo em tudo o que sei que assim
não tinha quase nada
levaram tudo e aí meus pais de tomar uma
decisão que a partir dali é tudo iria
mudar a minha vida
eles em vez de recuar eles decidiram que
iriam comprar um apartamento em um e aí
pra isso a minha mãe ver o camelô a
minha mãe basicamente ela viajava é uma
vez por mês
daqui até o paraguai e percorrer mais ou
menos 1.500 quilômetros dia da micro e
1500 quando de volta de ônibus não posso
dizer que minha mãe perdeu muito peso
só que eles tinham um objetivo muito
forte
conseguir um apartamento em um ano e aí
pra isso mesmo fez isso meu pai ficava
intercalando emprego dele
entre ficar ficar na barraca né quando
minha mãe não estava cuidando de mim
pela minha mãe perguntava e é os dois
tocaram isso durante um ano e depois de
um ano eles vão comprar um apartamento
porque na verdade eles não queriam um
apartamento ele queria um lugar que
pudesse me proteger
ele queria um lugar que pudesse proteger
a família deles e aí com isso eu aprendi
algumas coisas eu aprendi a ter um
pensamento empreendedor
aprendi a planejar aprendi sobre vendas
e aprendi a coisa mais complexa que eu
já aprendi na vida que a vida não é
fácil ela é super difícil mas saiu do
rio de janeiro pois a minha mãe vendia
brinquedo e aí você pensa assim é uma
criança na minha mãe ela ia era uma vez
por mês ela voltava sempre no domingo
então eu ficava esperando ele voltar
porque minha mãe ia voltar
e porque minha mãe trazer brinquedo ela
sempre pedia pra escolher um brinquedo
ela voltava assim no chão vários
brinquedos já eu tinha que escolher 11 e
obviamente o escolhido já vermelho numa
dessas aí e parecia assim que estava na
disney é porque vale era tipo assim era
a fantástica fábrica de chocolate só com
um brinquedo e minha mãe era uma honra
dos brinquedos é aí em modestas que ele
o nível vermelho mas teve um brinquedo
que mudou tudo um do absolutamente tudo
na minha vida
na verdade eu não escolhi a minha mãe
que me deu esse brinquedo era um pacote
de peças de montar porque esse mercado
mudou tudo na minha vida porque a parte
dele eu gerei eu comecei a desenvolver a
minha criatividade ea partir dele eu não
precisava criar mais nada eu já não
precisava ter mais nenhum brinquedo
porque eu criava as minhas histórias eu
criava os meus desafios e eu criava tudo
que eu precisava ter a não ser um
videogame mas aí a gente tira tá tirando
o videogame eu criava tudo inclusive o
meu mundo
então isso aqui tá dentro da minha casa
só que essa história ela termina comigo
indo para salvador
e aí quando fui para salvador é eu não
queria ir
só que eu percebi que meus pais
precisavam disso e vamos para salvador
engraçado que a vida te leva alguns
lugares mas ela tem um propósito aqui eu
encontrei o meu professor do ensino
o verdadeiro né o professor conhece como
professor
por que esse professor foi a pessoa que
me ensinou ensinar e aí pra isso
essa época já era adolescente eu faço
uma pergunta vocês alguém que sabe o que
é ácido ribonucleico quem sabe assim eu
não sei o que acha do rebu klayko mas eu
sei o quê movimento retilíneo uniforme
por incrível que pareça porque eu sei o
que é movimento retilíneo uniforme
porque quando na minha primeira aula de
física na primeira aula de física
essa é a velocidade média do movimento
retilíneo uniforme na primeira na minha
primeira aula de física o meu sonho
difícil entrou pegou a minha mão racha
foi até a janela e de repente prometra e
falou eu vou jogar bocha lá embaixo eu
sei que a distância
vocês vão cronometra a gente vai colocar
a os dados na fórmula e vocês vão
aprender velocidade média
pensando e fazendo um racha e vai jogar
negócio em baixo mas ao mesmo tempo eu
pensei o seguinte eu nunca vi esse tipo
de coisa acontecer vamos deixar esse
cara joga negócio em baixo não é
problema e ele jogou e jogou um negócio
lá embaixo
ele pegou os dados e colocou na forma
ensinou pra gente velocidade média e
logo em seguida ele falou o seguinte a
velocidade média essa fórmula está em
todos os carros
afinal de contas quilômetros por hora o
que foi nesse momento que a minha cabeça
explodiu porque naquele momento eu
consegui entender o quanto a minha mãe
viajava basicamente três mil quilômetros
por mês eo quanto eles meu pai e mãe
tinha que trabalhar conta que se
esforçavam para trabalhar e para eles
ter um sonho deles e aí eu pensei o
seguinte eu quero fazer o que esse cara
faz eu quero jogar borracha dos outros
pela janela sem a menor conseqüência 20
anos de vez em quando mas não era isso
que eu quero fazer o que esse cara faz
eu quero dar aula porque o que acabou
fazer não foi da aula foi mágica ele
acabou de fazer algo incrível
ele acabou de transformar uma borracha
uma ferramenta de física ele acabou de
fazer o quê exatamente a vida faz ele
usou o conteúdo eo processo
eu me lembro bem que esse processo me
dizia o seguinte vitor você não tem que
tirar dengue o que aprender
são coisas muito diferentes não tem
gravar um caso grave que você aprenda e
aí ele conseguiu através de uma borracha
me ensinar a ensinar na última fase
adulto
essa fase não há uma história essa fase
são várias histórias e aqui eu entendi o
quanto a vida sabe ensinar
aqui eu percebi que a vida não é do
ponto a ao ponto b
a vida é do ponto a ponto a agenda é
cíclica
porque quando era adolescente ainda
adolescente barra dupla neto estava
passando para a fase adulta
eu tive o meu primeiro emprego eu
trabalhava com física e criatividade ao
mesmo tempo trabalhava com fotografia
depois eu fui publicitário que
basicamente é planejamento criatividade
vendas
depois eu disse à empresa que
basicamente é planejamento um pensamento
empreendedor criatividade e vendas e eu
comecei a perceber que tudo que a vida
tinha ensinado tudo aquilo que eu tinha
pego como item de habilidade e tal eu
comecei a aplicar e aplicar na minha
vida e eu comecei a perceber que na
verdade eu só estava construindo novos
mundos com peças de montar
só que de forma diferente e eu resolvi
voltar para o rio
quando voltei para o rio há 11 anos
atrás eu não tinha nada absolutamente
nada eu não tinha dinheiro não tinha
perspectiva eu tinha uma empresa de
salvador que eu deixei pra mim pro rio
só que eu não vim com o que eu tinha
quando saiu da empresa
só que tinha uma coisa a chama que meu
pai mantinha
a todo momento eu pensava a mesma coisa
todo mundo que dessem alguma coisa de
errado pensava a mesma coisa eu pensava
se meu pai ea mãe conseguiram eu tenho
que conseguir e eu tinha um sonho o
sonho era ensinar a ensinar da mesma
forma que meu pai me ensinou meu pai e
me ensinaram em cima da mesma forma que
os meu professor de física me ensinou e
hoje como professor eu tento mostrar
para os meus alunos a caixa deles porque
nessa história eu não sou o professor
nessa história eles são professores os
professores porque é cada dia que eu dou
aula eu aprendo uma coisa diferente e eu
tenho que ensinar a eles como borrachas
e peças de montar podem alterar um mundo
deles completamente porque a vida é
cíclica
o rei a vida ela é uma rede em que todos
nós estamos conectados tentando ensinar
uns para os outros porque ela usa
totalmente conteúdo do processo
ela é mestre nisso porque ela pega os
nossos pontos de força para transformar
as nossas fraquezas porque ela nos
ensina ensinar e ela não é conseguir uma
nota 10
ela é você aprender e colocar as coisas
na sua caixa e eu pergunto a vocês o que
vocês aprenderam com a vida hoje quantas
pessoas te ensinaram algo acredite cada
coisa que uma pessoa fala é um item que
pode colocar aqui dentro porque todos
nós somos professores e hoje eu gostaria
de inspirar vocês a pegar as caixas de
vocês ensinarem para alguém alguma coisa
porque na verdade não é o quanto a gente
tira fora da gente pensa fala da caixa e
se encontra a gente coloca as coisas na
caixa sem derrubar coloca as coisas na
caixa e aproveitar o que a vida nos deus
eu
sei que não consigo mudar o mundo mas
sem mudar uma caixa
aquela pessoa que mudei vai conseguir
construir o mundo dela porque a vida é
uma grande sala de aula e eu gostaria de
agradecer aos meus professores para os
profissionais do ensino né
é óbvio que tem mais só que é eu tentei
focar nesses foi um dos que mais
marcaram alex autor de física os ame meu
primeiro professor na faculdade ea carla
o carro ea claudia meus professores
doutorados os meus professores da vida
causa augusto ana lúcia
a minha professora é na saúde e na
doença na alegria na tristeza na
carolina que não pôde estar aqui à minha
esposa e aos meus amigos aqueles que
ensinam todo dia e aos meus alunos
aqueles que sem eles eu não vivo
obrigado
[Aplausos]